you
[Music]
good afternoon everybody I'm one of the
founders and CEO of Kiwi and I'm here
with my teammate Robert who I know you
will hopefully get to meet as especially
during during the session and afterwards
as well so we're here to tell you a
little bit about what we do at Kiwi and
some of the takeaways we have had in the
context of machine learning as it
relates to IOT so just a little bit of
background about Kiwi and what we do or
who we are our our vision started out by
imagining a future in a world where
electrical outlets are not just the dumb
sources of electricity that they have
been for the last century or so but
rather they're actually a connected
network of powerful sensors that make
buildings more safe more convenient more
efficient and this was the vision that
got Jennifer and myself my co-founder
started on this path we started doing
this because we realized that we spent
about 90% of our times in indoors inside
buildings and unlike our cars who that
tend to continually improve with
technology building sent a lot behind
quite a bit they they feel crummy and a
quite static and we wanted to change
that so so as I was saying when we think
about buildings and the impact that they
have at least from an energy perspective
which is a big focus for Kiwi we we see
that buildings actually consume the
majority of energy use in in the United
States this this data is as of 2018 and
compared to all industrial applications
and all transportation buildings were
the largest consuming consumers of
electricity and so what that means is
that being able to have a make a change
and have have a slight improvement in
efficiency will have a huge economic and
environmental impact which is what
motivates us on a daily basis when we
look at building efficiency recent data
have shown that about 40 percent of that
energy use comes from
electronic appliances that get plugged
into the wall outlets these are things
that are not hardwired and for that we
use a term called plug loads and what
the Department of Energy has indicated
is that in 2017 they estimated that
about 40% and they're actually as a
estimating that it will continue to grow
at about 49% by 2040 so clearly it's
it's a big problem and it's growing and
it's not a surprise we all have a very
different lifestyles now as compared to
even 10 years ago we all use and operate
a whole lot more electronic appliances
and we bring those inside our the built
environment and the buildings and so
that it makes it makes total sense but
it's a problem that hasn't been
addressed and what makes us these plug
loads difficult to manage is of course
their massive scale there are about 20
billion outlets in the US alone and
unfortunately there's currently no
infrastructure for monitoring or
controlling them when it comes to
building management industries there's a
saying that they that that says you
can't manage what you can't measure and
the electrical outlets and plugs
definitely fall in that category and
lastly because occupants like us here
who don't necessarily think about how a
building runs they are the ones
interfacing with the electrical outlets
and the plug loads their behavior ends
up affecting the performance of the
building overall and so what we do at Q
is we try to address all these issues
through the power of using big data and
occupant engagement to bring about a
solution for plug loads that brings more
efficient and more comfortable buildings
around we are a software company and our
focus has been to to use data to bring
bring these changes about in our short
company history we've been around for
about three years we have been very
fortunate to work with leading
institutions like SFO Stanford
University MasterCard and even the Los
Angeles Unified School District and
what these institutions have been
working with us on has been to address
address the problem that I'm that I
mentioned earlier the way we do this is
that we believe data is the key in
unlocking this this problem and
addressing this issue so you may have
seen a lot of smart plugs out there you
may have them in your homes - may be
familiar with some of them and what I'm
here to tell you that we're different
from them so you may you may have seen
devices like this which I'm happy to
show show you more afterwards as well
you can come up they collect data as a
you know in the form of current and
voltage as a function of time so it's a
time series data and what all plug
manufacturers to do is that at best they
display that data to their customers
what we do however is that we actually
take it a few steps further than that so
what that means is that we use the basic
data and we extract court analytics from
it so we're able to answer questions
like what is getting plugged in who's
using it where is it located and how is
it being used what this does is that it
essentially generates an automatic
inventory that updates real time and
that makes the lives of these building
managers a lot easier we don't stop
there we actually go further in that we
extract we have business insights from
the way that the electrical outlets are
used so we're able to now start
predicting how the building is going to
be utilized and answer questions like
what's a good schedule for it
for a device to be set and when can we
turn it off so that we can avoid
electricity waste well it will a device
fail during a critical time and if so
will the manager at the building manager
have to scramble to fix that issue and
lastly how is that space being used as
we know in San Francisco for example
rent is extremely expensive and
companies try to minimize waste as much
and we're able to answer questions like
that so one one example that we may all
identify with is this is all in the
commercial space but in the residential
space imagine grandpa or grandma I
normally uses her coffeemaker at 9:00
a.m. in the morning and one one morning
she doesn't we're able to automatically
alert the caretaker to go check up on
her so we're able to extract a whole lot
of value from from the outlet data by
utilizing the data in a in a in a smart
way
our solution is a vertically integrated
hardware software analytics layer what
we do on the hardware side excuse me is
that we add custom firmware to existing
off-the-shelf plugs and enable them to
collect current and voltage data in a
way that is scalable so we are able to
deploy a hardware that's typically
targeted towards residential
applications for large commercial
buildings and have hundreds and
thousands of nodes operating at the same
time we enable data data flow from the
customer site to our cloud server where
the magic happens and we have interfaces
both for the building managers in the
form of a web app as well as for the
building occupants like us in the form
of a mobile app to enable everybody
looking at the same data and getting
their incentives aligned what we want to
focus on in the conversation today is
sort of share with you some of our
experiences and learnings and using ml
when it comes to IOT data and what are
some of the implications for that and
what are some of the tricks we've been
able to use that have worked well so in
that context I want to talk about two
features that use
ml that we are extremely excited about
because this will keep I'll keep
referring back to these two features
throughout the call the home the
conversation here
so the first one is automated device
classification you can think of the the
current data as a function of time as
being a signature for a particular
device that signature is different for a
laptop versus a fridge versus a desktop
computer for example and we have been
able to use ml to classify different
types of devices into into different
categories again what this does is that
it makes the the jobs of the building
manager is a lot easier because now they
have a automatic inventory that updates
real time and they don't have to worry
about managing manually thousands and
thousands of electronic appliances
that's the first feature and the second
feature is what we call learn scheduling
this is in the context of enabling waste
electricity waste especially to be
eliminated from from the use of
electronic appliances so we look at the
past usage pattern of a particular
appliance and we can predict whether in
the next 15 minutes or not the plug or
the appliance needs to be on if so we
turn the plug on and if if not we
actually shut the shut the plug off and
so what this is analogous to some extent
to the the automated faucets for example
that you see at the sink if nobody's in
front of them there's no water flowing
whereas if somebody actually is wanting
to use it then that's when the water
flows a similar analogy but except in
the context of electricity so those are
a couple of features that we are excited
about and we'll be referring to those as
we talk about this when we zoom in on
the sort of left-hand side of that
previous slide where the where the IOT
network is I want to zoom in to that a
little bit and tell you guys a little
bit more about how we do that and how
that's set up so we have the the smart
plugs that connect wirelessly to a
central gateway both of these have our
custom
and they enable a well-orchestrated
network of communication the Gateway is
specifically designed so that it
requires only outbound access to the
Internet and this is important from a
from a fire firewall setting and also a
security setting given that we're
dealing with building systems so from
there the data flows are cloud and if we
were to focus a little bit more on on
the cloud side of things we use then we
use a system where we have two different
sets of data flow our high resolution
data which is about once every second or
once every minute and most it gets
routed to to redshift and that's where a
lot of our real-time processing happens
on on the other hand our low resolution
data which is fed to Postgres database
on Heroku and is used for the user
interfaces is actually aggregated from
seconds to minutes and then hours and
that's what that's what the rest of the
interface is use I guess I am in an
isolated controlled environment lab
environment all of all of this seems
pretty simple and there's nothing that
one needs to be aware of however what
makes IOT interesting especially from a
data analysis perspective is that there
are a lot of unexpected challenges that
come up and the main and the more the
most difficult part of challenges are
the people so we have physical parts of
our system that are being touched and
used by individuals and you'd be
surprised to know what people can can do
with these things so we've had
situations where they just unplug the
the sensors they we've had situations
where they get destroyed they sometimes
they do get stolen unfortunately and not
to name any names well I think it was a
few months ago we actually had somebody
spilled juice over
the sensors and so stuff happens and
this is important from a from a data
analysis perspective and a data
management perspective because you can
never expect things that people can can
actually end up doing with the sensors
it makes for an interesting work
environment for sure the second category
are the sensors themselves so as much as
we'd like to think that hardware
manufacturing process is robust in
reality each of these units can actually
have issues so they can be calibrated or
they can lose calibration they can not
it is possible that some units don't
collect data or they don't transmit data
so that ends up affecting data quality
and also the the integrity of the data
as well and lastly our networking can be
affected so the wireless network between
the plugs and the and the Gateway on
side can be can be blocked we can't help
it if somebody all of a sudden decides
to put a metallic closet right in front
of our gate way of blocking essentially
all communication or if we lose power to
what to the plugs or the the Gateway
itself that that leads to data loss and
lastly because of because of that we end
up with a variable data frequency which
which makes it interesting from from a
data processing perspective so as part
of the talk today we wanted to share
with you a few tools that we have
learned in our experience with using IOT
data and machine learning at the same
time and share those with you so that
you can add that to your to your toolbox
in case it's relevant to what you guys
do in your in your work as well so the
first set of tools we capture are under
this umbrella of expectant expect the
unexpected and what we mean by that is
of course all the challenges I just
explained especially as a small young
company it's impossible for us to
imagine that we are what we have
currently in our database is everything
that could possibly happen so we have to
build ourselves against the the risk of
coming into unexpected situations and we
have some tools we want to share with
you in terms of how to do that so the
first tool we want to highlight is in
the process of model development what
you want to focus on and the takeaway
here is that you want to focus on what
we call a good data coding code and that
can mean a lot of different things that
can mean regularly occurring data data
without missing data points or high
quality data you can define it however
you want but the point is to start out
your modeling with good data before you
give it give it the more challenging
ones because if it's not able to handle
the the the good quality data there's no
way that it would be able to handle them
the more messy types of data so how you
want to avoid the situation where you
end up with garbage in garbage out
unfortunately so what you're seeing here
as an example is our power of wattage
data as a function of time for a
particular monitor so in the context of
learn scheduling the feature that I
mentioned where we automatically turn
off equipment you see that for this
particular monitor over four days there
is actually a pretty well regulated
repeating of the of the usage pattern so
you see you see them monitor being used
over time or doing the day over time and
at night it shuts down and that's where
you see the the plateau is at zero now
compare this against a situation like
this for the for the exact same days and
a different monitor and it's it's not
behaving as you would expect
so either the monitor is yeah is staying
on or there has been a challenge with
the plug or the or the networking of
some sort and the takeaway here is if
you are developing a model you want to
start out with number one to make sure
that you build it
just enough to handle the easy scenario
before you start feeding it the more
challenging one and of course as you
build your model you can always continue
to evolve it and make it better so that
ultimately it is able to handle
situations like number two but before
that don't do that and of course for us
as a as a young startup with a small
team we want to be a we want to be sure
that we're spending time on developing a
model that will pay off so this is
extremely important to run this test
before you do any real development the
second one is a trick that is somewhat
talked about even in the last talk a
little bit the idea is to be able to
generate data so again for us as a as a
young startup we don't necessarily have
a huge data set so when we're trying to
do other classification defining the the
type of the equipment that are getting
plugged into the plugs using their
signature what we noticed when we first
started working on this feature that is
that we had a lot of data on laptops and
monitors just by the nature of the
deployments and the clients we've had
but we had a lot fewer when it came to
fridges and microwaves so we had to be
creative in terms of creating datasets
that were completed and comparable so
that our model was able to distinguish
all of those so we used we use three
different types of approaches to bring
that about the first one we call point
noise so we start out with a with a
sample data you can imagine this is the
use of a laptop during the day and it's
shut shut off after the person goes home
that's the top data set so what we do is
we use the same sample and we
essentially create three new sets of
samples from that by point noise we
introduce noise in the sample data
points
to allow the model to establish and
evaluate a scenario where there are
variations either because of the
occupying behavior or device behavior
and we bring that in and that's the red
line you see in the bottom graph the
other approach we use the sample noise
where we shift the the the entire sample
up and down and this can simulate having
a different laptop or having a scenario
where a plug as has a slightly different
calibration and therefore systematically
higher or lower than the other ones and
the last scenario is is what we call
time shift this is to enable the model
to see a scenario where I where the the
laptop for example isn't necessarily
just being used during the hours of the
day but rather it's being used in in the
evening and so the entire sample is
getting shipped in time so through this
effort we have been able to quickly
allow the model to see the situations
that we haven't necessarily yet seen in
the real world and we've been able to
increase our sample size through this
approach the next tool that we want to
recommend is obviously a one for
monitoring the pipeline performance so
I'll walk through this through the
example of the chart that's that's here
and this is in the context of our
learned scheduling feature as I
mentioned earlier and our our model at
this point had only seen data from March
10th and March 11th which happened to be
Saturday and Sunday so it had only seen
weekend data up to that point it was too
early in the process for it to be able
to correctly assume and predict a
behavior so on Monday when people showed
up of course we we we see all this an
increase in the number of false
negatives that were were occurring the
false negative is one the the plug has
to be on but it's actually turned off
meaning that it's being used yet the
model assumes that it has to be turned
off and that's a bad scenario because
the last thing you want are a bunch of
angry clients wanting to use their
appliances and there's no power so we
had set up a specific monitoring that
only looked at the false negative
scenarios and as soon as that false
negative hit a threshold that was one we
knew we had to roll up our sleeves and
and get in there and at least manually
address address the issue you can also
imagine the same scenario if in the
world of a start-up all of a sudden
everybody has to come in all hands on on
a Saturday and all their electronics are
off because the model doesn't expect
people to be in on Saturdays so the
point is to make sure to monitor that
and of course be on call and ready to
address it manually if something like
that does happen so these three points
are are the situations where something
unexpected happens and you have to react
accordingly you have to setup yourself
well for success there the other set of
tools that I want to share with you are
more the scenario where we know what
challenges exist we've already sort of
talked about them previously and now
these are some tools that you can use
for the challenges that you know about
and how to address them so that's what
we want to do is essentially minimize
the effects of the challenges that you
know you're gonna see so the first
example is for a recommendation
especially when you're dealing with IOT
networks is to incorporate system health
information so we spent a lot of time
building the IOT network but we've
probably just spent just as much time if
not more building the monitoring system
for the for the physical world as well
and so this is probably going to be best
understood by looking at the at the
chart here what you see here are the
hourly data for a monitor a computer
monitor data as a function of time over
over about a month so you see regular
periods of
of offer zero usage which one may
typically associate with the weekends
and when we feed this data to our model
and and try to estimate the probability
of the monitor being used on a Friday if
we were to just look at this data what
we would assume is that on March 22nd
and March 29th which both happened to be
Friday's the plug is off therefore
there's a high probability that this
monitor isn't being used on Fridays so
that would be one conclusion but then
when we overlay the system health
information on top what you see in the
red is the failure rate of communication
between the plug and the Gateway you all
of a sudden notice that around the March
22nd timeframe there were actually four
days of network outage and so the the
the data was was indicating or was lost
in that period and it was zero century
but the model didn't know the difference
so here the probability of the plug
being turned off on a Friday is actually
much higher because we exclude that
those four days and this has especially
been important for a man from a data
analysis perspective and reporting
perspective as well because challenges
like this do happen in the physical
world the second set of tools is or the
trick I should say that we learn what
was extremely useful was in transforming
data from sort of a continuous platform
to discrete this was especially
important and when we look at different
types of equipment so our system needs
to be able to handle devices regardless
of whether they're a laptop or a monitor
or whatever else there they may be and
when we look at the power data as a
function of time again this is our leaf
or a particular monitor you see that
something like a 17 watt reading for
this monitor is actually at it it means
that the monitor is running at full
capacity
when we look at the same type of plot
for a laptop instead a 17 watt usage is
actually probably indicating standby
it's not at full capacity yet our models
and being able to understand when to
turn equipment on or off or when to how
to detect the different types of
equipment they need to be able to use
all the data regardless of the the
performance and the time and the type of
devices is that they are and so the the
trick that has worked really well for us
in this context has been to transform
the continuous data hourly data for
example into into discrete so instead of
looking at wattage as a function of time
we start looking at at the state instead
so for the monitor it ends up being a
binary set of data in that the monitor
is either on or off and for the laptop
it ends up having three states so it's
either on and fully in use or it's on
standby or it's completely turned off so
what this enables us to do now is to
feed the same data and and to the same
model and they enable it to look at all
all of them at the same time what's
really cool about this is that this
particular feature is a ssin is actually
using ml and itself so we're using a
mouth to help another ml process which i
think is pretty awesome so in summary we
have we wanted you to walk away with
some takeaways in terms of specific
tools that you can use especially in the
context of IOT if that's what you're
what you're working on and we're happy
to talk more about that either during
office hours or during the networking
event but before closing out I want to I
want to say a special thanks to you guys
for being here and a special thanks to
Robert who is here and most of this work
is thanks to his hard work so with that
I want to thank you and see if you guys
have any questions do you have to worry
about privacy issues
in your work in this company because
you're basically inferring what type of
appliances people are using and when
they're using it and things like that
yeah
good question so the types of clients
that we have had so far are obviously
our commercial commercial States
commercial buildings that own the entire
set of you know they own the building
and they own everything that's in it so
from from the perspective of our clients
it's something that it's under their
umbrella and they have to manage of
course there's a lot that that can be
inferred from it but it's used in the
context of business applications and and
what we typically do is that we don't
actually include any personally
identifiable information with that so
what we collect is essentially current
and voltage as a function of time the
rest of it which is the personally I
didn't identifiable we don't collect and
we don't display so that's how we
address that issue what's your training
set so let's say you've never seen a
hairdryer how do you like manually
collect data about plugging different
hair dryers and yeah yeah good question
so I'll kick that up and I'll let Robert
expand on that or do you what do I ever
do you want to just talk about sure sure
yeah so for the most part most of the
devices that we're working with are ones
that are pretty common in offices so a
lot of monitors a lot of laptops laptop
docks desktops but we have done a little
bit of work on mining our own data where
we actually sort of try to create
Network effects and get people to get
their friends to plug in the craziest
things in their houses so we can get a
little bit more of that but it does help
that we're mostly focused on similar
kinds of deployments everywhere that we
go with that if you are interested in
having data collected let us know if we
could lend you some of these what
hello hello okay one one question I had
I noticed that Los Angeles School
District was one of the I used to work
at a school district and we were not
allowed to have coffee makers I think it
was like a fire concern or something
like that do you
you just currently use the system is
like an enforcement thing so like the
school district can say there's there's
a coffee maker here we're gonna remove
it and good question so not to pick on
on LAUSD or anything but our clients but
that actually is pretty common not just
for school districts but even at a
companies there are certain types of
equipment that are not allowed at an
airport you can imagine there are safety
issues so there are certain types of
equipment that should not be allowed we
haven't had clients use that in that
context they would just like to know
about it so that they can be prepared
for for the for the situation when
something or if something were to happen
so LAUSD specifically as an example and
they have been interested in in knowing
what is going on inside the schools they
have a thousand schools a lot for them
to manage and their electricity bills of
course are increasing at a five percent
rate per year so it's it's a huge
problem and the main issue when we first
met them was that they didn't even know
if electronic appliances were something
that they had to worry about or not so
giving them that first layer of
visibility into this is what is going on
inside your buildings was really what
they felt they were focused on rather
than sort of enforcement of rules at
that point any other questions well I
have a remark which is that it seems
like a lot of what you figured out is
that there's a real story in the real
world behind what what the data has so
for example when you were showing how
there were missing points but it was
actually because the device was off
that's something you can only know by
knowing the real world behind your data
do you think that IOT is unique in this
regard
that's a good question I I feel like it
can't be unique I mean there are a lot
of things about IOC that makes it fun to
work on
but knowing knowing information when it
comes to model development and doing
anything with the data any sort of
quantitative or even qualitative data
you may know is going to be helpful in
what you do in in analyzing your data so
I in the context of that that can't be
unique to IOT even if you know for us we
need to know what may have happened at
the deployment we actually make a point
of knowing okay at which customer side
did we did we get a call who's who's
been complying well and who hasn't so we
even keep this information in mind to
know what good datasets we may have
coding code and which ones to first feed
into the model so we we use data that's
captured that's not captured within the
database to to affect our modeling and I
don't think that's I don't I don't
assume I can presume that that's unique
to IO to
[Music]